We've got a hypothesis that we're still
working out that supported to some
degree by the relevant literature.
So imagine that you're looking for a
stable partner.
Right.
So you might think well what do you want
in a stable partner and at least in
principle one of the things you don't
want is too much mismatch between you
and that person on the five fundamental
dimensions.
So for example if you're really
extroverted and you have a really
introverted partner you're going to
engage in continual conflict about how
much social activity the two of you
should should be should should what
subject yourself to and it's very very
difficult for people who broadly differ
widely differ on those dimensions to
come to consensus because it's not just
a matter of opinion.
Right it's really a matter of different.
If you're looking at extremes of really
different types of people then the thing
about introverts is they just don't
enjoy large scale social interaction
much one on one they're often fine.
But in a group they don't like that.
And it tires them out whereas a real
extrovert it's like you isolate them and
they just wither on the vine because a
huge part of what actually motivates
them in a positive way is tangled up
with social interaction.
And so if you're an agreeable person and
you have a particularly disagreeable
partner you're also going to run into
problems because the agreeable person
will say whatever you want whenever and
the agreeable disagreeable person will
say Well I'd like to know what the hell
you want for a change and be much more
harsh and much more demanding in the
situation and the agreeable person is
going to find the disagreeable person
harsh and unpleasant and disagreeable
person is going to find the agreeable
person wishy washy and unable to stand
up for themselves.
And again that's that's actually one of
the primary sources of tension between
men and women because women tend to be
higher in agreeableness than men.
It's about half a standard deviation
which is quite quite quite quite a large
difference by psychological standards.
And so what that means I probably
haven't got this statistic quite right.
But I think I've got it about right.
What that means fundamentally just so
you have some sense of how large the
effect that is is that if you have a
group of men and women and you pick out
random pairs the woman is going to be
more agreeable than the man 60 percent
of the time.
So that's not an overwhelming proportion
but it's a reliable and it's quite it's
quite large.
By psychological standards.
So there's the problem with
agreeableness with conscientiousness.
Well if you're conscientious you're
industrious and orderly and orderly
people seem to be sensitive to disgust
which is something we'll talk about in
detail later.
We've had a hard time specifying exactly
what makes industrious people
industrious because it's hard to come up
with an animal model for that sort of
thing and there's no theoretical model.
But our latest idea is that it's not my
idea it's actually the idea of my
graduate student Christine Brophy is
that industrious people find it
unpleasant and unsettling to not be
doing something.
So it isn't so much that industriousness
makes them happy or fills them with
positive emotion.
That would be more extraversion right
because extroversion is the positive
emotion to mention.
It's that industrious people can't stand
sitting around doing nothing.
And you know this is speculation but you
know human beings are obviously always
engaged in the exchange of labor
especially the reciprocal exchange of
labor and you can imagine that in a
community where everyone knows everyone.
The people who work hard are going to be
pretty irritated on a fairly chronic
basis with the people who are completely
unproductive.
And my suspicions are that plenty of
people who are completely unproductive
in the history of our of the evolution
of our species were wiped out by people
who were unhappy with their lack of
productivity.
And so I think generally speaking human
beings have this sense of ethical
obligation with regards to one another
to share labor and people who are
conscientious really really feel that so
they feel bad if they're not busily
working on something that's productive
all the time.
And so the advantage to being with
someone conscientious is well they're
going to work like mad.
But the disadvantages there they're
So you know if you're looking for a
partner that you want to relax with or
have fun with or who isn't uptight then
a conscientious person is probably not a
very good choice.
On the other hand if you're a
conscientious person and you're living
with someone who's really an
conscientious that's good because they
might be able to help you relax but
you're not going to be happy with them
because they don't work nearly as hard
as you do.
But even worse on the orderly dimension
you know some of you have had roommates
and maybe you're more orderly than your
roommate.
What does it mean.
Means you're annoyed by mass before they
are and you don't have to be annoyed by
mass much before you're less orderly
roommate for you to be the one that's
always running around picking things up.
And so actually one of the things that's
emerged from the psychometric analysis
is that women are slightly more orderly
than man and I suspect that has
something to do with.
What would you call it inequitable
distribution of housework.
Because even if your imagine that your
proclivity is to be triggered by a
disorder twenty five seconds before your
partner's well you're going to end up it
doesn't take much difference for you to
be the one that's always concerned about
the mess first.
So anyways and so if you're a really
orderly person and you live with a
disorderly person.
Well good luck getting along with them.
They're going to regard you as like
uptight and and overconcerned with
details.
And and well and unwilling to relax
that's for sure and they're going to
regard you as well just a bloody mess.
And how can anyone possibly live with
someone like you.
And so.
So another reason why it's useful to
understand your personality is because I
think it gives you a better crack at
finding someone that you can actually
live with over the long run and we don't
know what the optimal.
I don't think you want to live with
someone who is exactly like you.
Because then both of you have the same
strengths and weaknesses and there's a
bit of a problem there.
Right.
Because maybe an agreeable person can
use a bit of disagreeable person around
them to balance each other out and vice
versa.
Right.
So we don't understand the optimal
balance for for a long term thriving in
a relationship.
But I think we do understand the fact
that if you're too different in your
traits that where you are different is
going to constitute a chronic source of.
Conflict.